شهد الجمهور السوداني الثنائيه متناغمه
خطفت الانظار ونالت الاشادات الفنان
السوداني احمد الفنانه روبي كمال المعروفه
بروبي او رؤى كمال معروفه بروبي
ظهر في مسلسل سكر الضياع وفازه بقلوب
المشاهدين من خلال ثنائيه رشا وعبادي
[موسيقى]
سلسله زوجان ولكن الكوميديه التي اذيعت
اولى حلقاتها على منصه التواصل في اكتوبر
الماضي وتتناول الخلافات الزوجيه في قالب
طريف
روبي هي في الاساس طبيبه اسنان احمد هو
مطرب وفنان له رصيد كبير من الاغاني
والحفلات وهم ضيوفنا اليوم في صباح
العربيه ولكن نتابع هذا التقرير معكم
[موسيقى]
خطفها الانظار احبهما الجمهور وشغله منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي الفنان السوداني احمد
الدقر وطبيبه الاسنان رؤى كمال
شنو
ذمتك قديشك الحرامي
كان اول ظهور لهما في المسلسل السوداني
سكه الضياع الذي وصف بانه اختراق
العمل الدرامي والمسرحي السائده بالسودان
وطبعا استعرض العمل الكثير من المشاهد
التي جمعت حدث ثنائي في قصه رائعه نالت
المتابعه انا البنت الحرامي همم
تكررت هذه الثنائيه مره اخرى وتصدرت
اهتمام المشاهد السوداني عبر السلسله
زوجان ولكن التي تحاكي واقع الحياه
الزوجيه التي لا تخلو من المشكله وقد تمت
معالجه القصه في قالب دراما مشيع حقق
الكثير من المشاهدات
احمد
لا يوجد
لصباح العربيه نحكي قصه نجاح هذا الثنائي
من السودان الريان الظاهر
[موسيقى]
انت كده كده
الكره الارضيه
طيب
للفنانه روبي كمال وينضم الينا ايضا
الفنان احمد الجقر احمد روبي اهلا بكم
منورين صباح العربيه شكرا على تواجدكم
معانا مبروك هذا النجاح
اهلا ومرحبا بكم صباح الخير عليكم صباح
الخير على كل الناس اللي بيشاهدونا صباحكم
خير صباح النور طيب احمد انت مغني وملحن
وشاعر روبي طبيبه اسنان مع كل هذه
المفارقه نجحتما في اول عمل النجاح
اجيب لك هذا النجاح نخلي روبي تسلم على
الناس
العربيه وصباح العربيه صباحكم فل يا رب
الله يسعدكم هلا عرفت سر نجاح يا احمد من
دون ما تحكي
هو البدايه كانت في سكه الضياع اه ممكن
تكون صدفه
بعداك ممكن تقول لي السرو ممكن يكون
التوفيق من رب العالمين زائد الكيمياء
بيني وبين الزميله وكمان
فالحمد لله يعني الناس من اسكندريه
[موسيقى]
خلي الايمان قلت لكم
بس بدي اسال روبي انه في اصوات يا روبي عم
بتنادي اليوم بجزء ثاني من مسلسل سكه
الضياع اللي يعرض في رمضان السابق شو ردك
انت وهل بالامكان ذلك
والله كنا بدنا نتمنى ان يكون في سكه
ضيعته لكن
لظروف كثيره منها الانتاج وحاجات كثيره
لكن ان شاء الله جايين بالاجمل والمسلسل
الجديده الاولى الاسم احمد
المسلسل الجديد ان شاء الله
في رمضان
طيب العمل تضمن يا روبي ويا احمد بعض
المشاهد الرومانسيه واعتبر انه شيء جديد
في الدراما السودانيه كيف تلقيتهما ردود
والله طبعا
السودان فوقه رومانسيه لكن طبعا احنا شويه
كده ان انا الخجل وعندنا حدود يعني في
الحاجات دي لكن ممكن في البدايات الناس
شويه نحنا تعرضنا مثلا كان فرد فعل في
ردود فعل كانت جميله
في حين انه نحن عاملين حدود شديد يعني في
الرومانسيه
في ناس قبلات وفي ناس ما قبلت لكن
الاغلبيه كانت انه هي حابه تشوف همم دراما
جديده حابه ان السودانيين يقدر يعبر عن
حاجاته من جوه الحب بالنسبه للطرف الاول
والطرف الثاني فا الاغلبيه حبه الحاجه دي
يعني في التجري ولا خير
وما بيحبوا او كده ف- اا دايما بس
الرومانسيه بتاعتنا دائما في الدراما
بتكون مغلفه كده بالكلمات شويه بتكون همم
قولي احمد مثلا اكتب لكن همم ان شاء الله
ده هيكون الطبيعي روبي روبي انت عمرك
استغليتي فرصه التمثيل مع احمد لك نفسي عن
غضبك وزعلك الحقيقي منه في الحياه مثلا
كان في مشهد غضب يلا نستغل الفرصه عم
بنمثل بغضب اكثر
ههه
ههه لا والله لا ب- اا
استغليت الفرصه عشان بيناتنا مثلا حاجه
وكده لو هو في العموم انا في العموم انا
بشوف انه التمثيل بالنسبه لك روبي متنفس
يعني مثلا كنت باقول لاحمد دايما انه مثلا
نفسي مثلا اعمل شخصيات مثلا سايكوباتك كده
يعني همم امراض نفسيه حاجاتكم لايكات كده
عشان انا في الحياه ما باقدر اكون كده في
التمثيل بالنسبه ليه متنفس للحاجات دي
اللي ما بيقدر اكون شريره مثلا في الحياه
نفسي اكون كده اعمل ادوار كده يعني فيها
شر وحاجات وكده فبالنسبه للمتنفس لكل حاجه
في الحياه ما بالضروره للشيخ او كده
وبعدين احمد يعني ههه
ههه
طيب نشوف مقطع لتمثيلكم مع احمد وروبي
ونرجع لكم
والله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ايش هذا الكريم
ااا نحنا شغالين ان شاء الله في مسلسل
اسمه الزان ده حيعرض في رمضان باذن الله
نحن المناسبه من هنا طالعين طوالي ماشيين
التصوير
[ضحك]
المسلسل الجديد هاي للتصوير يعني معلش
ظهرنا لكم
الشخصيه اللي في المسلسل الجديد يعني ههه
بين الممثلين
بيقربكم من بعض اكثر
شوفي
سبحان الله شوف الكاميرا او الكاميرا دي
بتكشف لك حتى اذا في كيمياء والممثلين في
الحقيقه مع بعض يعني بيظهر في الكاميرا
فانا بشوف انه طول ما الناس مثلا بيناتها
كيمياء والعلاقات برر اوف كاميرات كويسه
بيسهر دائما في الكاميرا
فالحاجات دي بتبانش ليه يعني طول ما
الممثل اللي معك انت قادره تتواصل معه
بطريقه كويسه انتم في الحياه يعني في في
لينك بيناتكم قادرين تتواصل كويس على طول
بيسهر الكلام ده في الكاميرا
كملي يا روبي
مش معروف
يا روبي
التفاهم والبيناتنا مثلا
يكون بيناتنا اعمال كثيره عشان كده دائما
بيسالوني انه انت دائما بتمثلي مع احمد او
كده فدي اجابه السؤال يعني تمام طيب احمد
شهدناك همم شاركت في كتابته الحلو
لماذا لا تشارك بصوتك الجميل في اعمال
الدراميه اخرى
اه انا علي 17 سنه بغني وبكتي وبالحن كده
فالفتره الجايه دي صراحه انا ضاغط اكثر
على التمثيل يعني التجربه الدراميه على
اساس انه حابه اغير شويه يعني انا ليس 17
سنه بغني فا ما بحس انه في جديد لكن هسه
جديد بالنسبه للدراما اا حاسس انه في قبول
اكبر في حب اكبر فااه
هاضغط شويه على الدراما الفتره الجايه
يعني
احنا اكيد بنشكركم جزيل الشكر للفنانه
روبي كمال وايضا الفنان احمد شكرا احمد
وروب نورتونا شكرا جزيلا لكما